Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie! We
have our first official look at the
Morbius character ahead of the trailer
that they're going to be dropping next week,
so well break it down. If you're new to
the channel we're also doing a movie
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be subscriber and leave all
your predictions for the Morbius movie
if it wasn't clear this is going to be a
spinoff of the venom movie yes it is
related to what's going on with their
spider-man plans inside the venom verse
we know a little bit about how that's
going to work I'll explain that after I
talk about what's going on with the
actual Morbius movie cannot wait to see
J Jonah Jameson showing up in a
post-credits scene posting about
vampires. It's going to be fun
people are saying that this teaser
leaked but I think that Sony actually
dropped this on purpose in advance of
the trailer just to get people hyped up
if we're the most part I think people
are happy with the CG special effects
because it does look pretty comic book
accurate but this doesn't give you a
really good idea for what the actual
movie is going to feel like it just
gives you an idea for what he's going to
look like it's a picture of him right
after he's gotten done feeding on
someone and it's an homage to this comic
book panel like an over-the-shoulder
shot he's looking to see if someone
caught him feeding oh my god what's
going on here because he can't control
his hunger if you're a big fan of the
Wesley Snipes blade franchise way back
in the day there were originally plans
to do the Morbius character in one of
those sequels they even have a deleted
scene from the first blade movie they
were going to introduce him during the
sequel before Guillermo del Toro came on
and did his version of Blade 2 the
footage is kind of janky but this is
that deleted scene
I never thought I'd be so happy to see
the Sun Rise
I need to get you back to the lab if I'm going to cure you. it's over
you keep you're cure. I've never felt better
besides as long as there's a war going on I still have a job to do.
then your back on the clock.
I'm a big fan of Guillermo del Toro but
it would have been cool to see that
version of Morbius if that had panned
out if you have no idea who the Morbius
character is or you never read the
classic spider-man comics he is a
spider-man character he debuted during
amazing spider-man in the early 70s it
was basically Marvel wanting to do their
version of a dracula character because
the 70s was a really big time for the
dracula character in pop culture so
Marvel just wanted to get in on that
Morbius was their attempt in an original
character based on Dracula though but
the funny thing about this is because
Sony doesn't have the rights to do the
Dracula character Marvel Studios does
because of the way the comic books
worked out and where the Dracula
character debuted in Marvel Comics
there's a rumor right now that Dracula
is actually going to show up during the
werewolf by night moon Knight series
that they're doing and during the Blade
movie that they're going to be doing with
Mahershala ali during Marvel phase 5
maybe as part of their grand sharing
arrangement with the spider-man
character Marvel will also loan out the
Dracula character for their Sony venom
verse to do Morbius stuff with and
sequels if the first movie is successful
but the whole idea of Sony doing Morbius
is them testing the waters with other
spin-off movies they of course want to
create their own version of the MCU
because it's been so successful for
Disney and Marvel and as part of the way
the rights with the spider-man character
work they have access to over 900
different characters Morbius is called
the living vampire but he only has
vampire like qualities he didn't get his
abilities through the vampire bite like
most do he started out as a Nobel
prize-winning biological scientist he
had this rare condition that was eating
his cells alive so he developed a
treatment using vampire bat;s blood and
electroshock therapy when he eventually
tried it on himself that caused an
accident that gave him his vampire like
qualities turning him into quote-unquote
a living vampire the way that Sony and
the venom verse is setting him up though
is to be an antihero just like the venom
character yes I definitely think that
they're setting them all up for a crossover in maximum carnage so Morbius
will wind up teaming up with venom you
know because of the Sony Marvel sharing
deal Tom Holland's spider-man will also
crossover with them eventually too you
may have also seen the rumors about what they're doing with J jonah Jameson so
Sony controls the JJ character they
loaned him out to the MCU for spider-man
far from home for that great post-credit
scene I thought it was a great way to
reintroduce the character and also sort of connected
to the Tobey Maguire spider-man era because they kind of skipped over
J Jonah Jameson during Andrew Garfield's run so if you haven't seen it the rumor
is now that Sony's going to use him as an
early point of crossover to weave
together all their venom burst movies in
the Tom Hollands spider-man MCU movies
so he showed up at the end of that movie
so he exists in the MCU now but the
rumor now is that he's going to cameo
during the Morbius movie and during
venom two in the same type of role doing
the same thing just total posting
about the main character of each of
those different movies so you can
imagine him going on and on about
vampires existing in the real world you
thought they were fake no they're
totally real we have live footage we're
going to air it now is a really easy slam-dunk so
I high-five whoever had the idea to use
J jonah Jameson to connect all these
dots together if you didn't see it recently to Sony also created a special
separate real website that you can visit
for the Daily Bugle dot net that was the
one that they referenced during
spider-man far from home post credits
scene Daily Bugle Dot Net J jonah Jameson has a live report if you go to the
website it's basically him going on and
on about all these crazy theories about
why Avengers endgame and the snap
happened why everyone came back about
the elementals that Mysterio created how
there are weird creatures running around
so Sony is now using as a viral marketing place for all their spider-man
related stuff and that'll probably wind
up including venom stuff when we get to
venom two coming out later this year in
Morbius later this summer really good
example of how they've used that for
viral marketing is that after spider-man
far from home came out the movie was
done they didn't shoot any new footage
for the movie itself but they shot a
bunch of new promos with JK Simmons
doing his J jonah Jameson thing is if
you were in his studio and he was still
reporting on spider-man stuff
J jonah Jameson here spider-man a
psychopath wielding powers he has no
right to possess trying to pass himself
off as a hero well let me tell you
something kid you're no hero Mysterio
that's a hero you are a criminal a
miscreant a masked Marauder a menace
thanks for watching don't forget to Like
and subscribe so that's not something
that they did for the spider-man far
from home movie that's just something
that they're doing with this new Daily
Bugle dot net web site I know there are a
lot of questions about how spider-man is
going to figure into all this in later
this summer Marvel is going to start
shooting spider-man 3 so are they going
to have some sort of post credits tag in
that that will imply how he will
eventually crossover with the venom
characters when Kevin Feige made the
announcement about the new sharing deal he referenced the multiverse in
spider-man jumping between cinematic
universes in addition to different
planets at the multiverse right now Sony
is developing a Madam web movie my
early guesses is that they'll use Madam
web is a way to explain how he crosses
universes because otherwise you'd have
to use someone like Doctor Strange or
scarlet witch or someone capable of that
level of technology or magic and it
sounds like based on the sharing
arrangement between Marvel and Sony Sony
has the rights to reference any spider-man related stuff from the MCU
but not the Avengers not the quantum
realm or anything like that so I don't
think that the quantum realm is going to
be the way that they used to get
spider-man between Sony's venom first in
the MCU the Morbius movie was shot to
make it look like it was happening in
New York City in venom - looks like it's
shooting scenes set in and around New
York City
spider-man is local to New York City even though technically he's in the MCU
right now you can kind of see that
they're bringing these characters into
each other's orbits eventually they'll
start crossing over probably in advance
of a big maximum carnage team-up movie where they all team up against the
carnage character so most important
characters in this movie are Jared
Leto's Michael Morbius character who
becomes Morbius the living vampire his
love interest Martine Bancroft who herself becomes a vampire eventually in
the locust crown aka the hunger character played by Matt Smith you heard
it right Matt Smith is going to be the
villain of the Morbius movie he's not
quite the exact same thing as Morbius in
the comics but he has the same blood
disease that eventually causes him to
have to feed on other living things in
order to survive so he's also very
vampire like we don't have to wait that
long before they're going to drop the
actual trailer that's happening Monday
of course I'll do a Easter Egg video for
it and we'll find out what the movie is
actually going to feel like I think we
all kind of wondered what venom was
going to be before we actually saw a
footage but at least for right now it
seems like they've nailed the look down
so everybody just post her reactions
in the comments and let me know what do you want them to do with the Morbius
character inside this larger connected
spider-man envenom universe I know that
a lot of people asking if this is going
to prevent Jared Leto from ever playing
the Joker again there is a version of
the Jared Leto Joker that's going to be
used during the birds of prey movie but
Jared Leto himself was actually filming
the Morbius movie when they were
shooting birds of prey so we need Joker
stuff that you see happening during
birds of prey next month because the
movie is coming out really soon is going to be a body double or hinges off screen
it's not Jared Leto actually being in
the movie himself let me know if there's
any bonus videos that you want me to do
our big requests for spider-man videos
while you wait for everything click here
for that brand-new Doctor Strange two
announcement that Marvel just made and
click here for my new Deadpool 3 video
thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!